when i was younger i wanted to be a spy
but in many ways i think being a
scientist is like being a spy
i mean i'm obtaining secret information
just instead of from governments or
criminal organizations from cells which
can sort of be thought of as containing
secret information because we need
special tools to detect their signals
this is not a trivial thing to do and on
my quest through science i'm always keen
to learn how to become more intelligent
which is what we're going to talk about
in this video
and the emphasis is on the word more as
we already are intelligence
but as i will share in this video there
are some very simple things you can do
to repair even more intelligence
as earlier this year i read the book how
spies think 10 lessons in intelligence
this book is written by sir david o'manz
former director of gchq the government
communications headquarters here in the
uk who intercept communications and
gather digital intelligence
in house by think david shares the
methodology used by british intelligence
agencies to reach judgements establish
the right level of confidence and act
decisively
as david explains the more we understand
about the decisions we have to take the
less likely it is we will dock them make
bad choices or be seriously surprised
much of what we need can come from
sources that are open to anyone provided
sufficient care is taken to apply
critical reasoning to them
so david offers this book his lessons
from the world of secret intelligence
as he's learned the hard way that
intelligence is uh difficult to come by
and is always fragmentary and incomplete
and is sometimes wrong
but used consistently and of
understanding of its limitations
it can shift the odds in the nation's
favor or in your favor
and this couldn't be more important to
understand now than ever in our
well we are being overwhelmed with
information from social media and other
digital sources all the time
but are we more or less
ignorant with this additional
information
um well i'm not going to answer that
because i didn't have an answer
but why i think time is better spent is
learning how to navigate with this
increased information inflow and how to
distinguish the facts from the fiction
the jokes from the um
anyway and how to make better decisions
now there are 10 official lessons in
david's book but haven't given it some
force and intelligence of my own
i think they can be summarized into
into about six lessons
the first four of which are summarized
by the seas model
and the seas model lays the foundation
for the lessons
so the first s stands for situational
awareness of what is happening and what
we face now
e for explanation of why we are seeing
what we do and underlying motivations
often our weaknesses come from
misunderstanding others their motives
are bringing culture and backgrounds
the second e is for estimates and
forecasts of how offence may unfold
and then the second answer is for cheeky
science obviously
i am taking it for strategic notice of
further issues that may be a challenge
in the longer term
so that's the model now for the lessons
lesson one situational awareness
our knowledge of the world is always
fragmentary and incomplete and is
sometimes wrong
and so given that the information is
limiting i may be wrong at best we can
generate hypotheses about the world
around us and how to act and use that to
guide our decisions
we are often given a lot of new
information of which we then have to
decide what to do with this new
information to update our degree of
belief the way david suggests we go
about this is through the use of
bayesian inference
so yes as indicated by the equation
bayesian inference is a method of
statistical inference used to update the
probability for a hypothesis as more
evidence or information becomes
available
so what this equation shows
is when h equals hypothesis and e equals
evidence
the probability for my hypothesis given
the new evidence equals the probability
of the hypothesis prior to the evidence
multiplied by the probability of the
evidence given the prior hypothesis
divided by the probability of the
evidence
now because that probably didn't make
much sense if you're unfamiliar with
bayesian inference there'll be an
example later where we use it
but obviously we're not going to be
sitting down and doing some math every
time we make a decision but i think it's
useful to have it as a sort of framework
as to how we are rationalizing this new
information
so once you have the facts
the facts need explaining and that's
lesson number two
the bottom line here is that context is
needed to infer meaning the same facts
can have opposite interpretations
david tells this fun story that he had
from another guy bertrand russell
known as the chicken espionage story
imagine a chicken farm in which the
chickens conduct an espionage operation
on the farmer perhaps by hacking into
his computer
they discover that he is ordering large
quantities of chicken foods
the joint intelligence committee of
chickens meet
what do they conclude is it that the
farmer has finally recognized that they
deserve more foods or that they are
being fattened up for the kill
perhaps if the experience of the
chickens has been of a happy outdoor
life
then their past experience may lead them
to be unable to conceive of the
economics of chicken farming as seen by
the farmer on the other hand chickens
kept in their thousands in a large tin
sheds may well be all too ready to
attribute the worst motives to the
farmer it is the same secret
intelligence the same fact but with two
opposite interpretations
this is true of most factual information
another example involves the use of
arbasian inference calculation is an
interaction david had with tony blair
and so in this interaction tony black
correctly guessed that david's
background was in defense
and when david asked tony blau why
he replied that it was because his shoes
were shined
those used to working with the military
had retained the habit of cleaning their
shoes regularly
so you can use bayesian reasoning to
test the hypothesis
why this time the hypothesis h is d for
defense
and the evidence is still the evidence
but the evidence is that the shoes are
shined
so we can work out the probability that
david works in defense given the fact he
has shiny shoes
equals the probability of people who are
in defense
multiplied by the probability of having
shiny shoes given that they work in
defense divided by the probability of
people having shiny shoes
so this table shows the numbers for each
of these probabilities
so by looking at the table we can see
that by using bayesian reasoning the
chances of tony blair's hypothesis being
true is almost double what would be
expected from a random guess
and that's because the number of people
who work in defence is a hundred out of
two thousand
so one twentieth whilst assuming that
his shiny shoes indicates that he's more
likely to come from defense
he can reduce that probability down to
112
70 over 830
you can pause and check the numbers
should you wish
now tony clearly didn't go whip out his
calculator when he said this to david
well i mean i wasn't there so i don't
actually know but i don't think he did
my impression is that we should just be
using bayesian inference as more of a
framework to just
make rational decisions
but what both of these stories the one
with tony blair and the chickens
tao
is the importance of context and
explanations
and the thing is this actually raises
interesting cautions for artificial
intelligence and decision making and the
dangers of letting a machine
infer an explanation of what is
occurring especially if it doesn't have
the context
but anyway
given that there is often multiple
explanations for a given fact how do we
know which one to choose
the one with the most evidence for it
right
wrong
as a general rule it is the explanatory
hypothesis with the least evidence
against it that is the most likely to be
the best one for us to adopt
this is a very simple fact i think at
least i do easily forget
in fact it's really important for
science to avoid the inductive fallacy
trap of thinking that being able to
collect more and more evidence in favor
of our proposition
necessarily increases confidence in it
by choosing the hypothesis that has the
least evidence against it you avoid the
bias that could come from unconsciously
choosing evidence to collect that is
likely to support a favored hypothesis
similarly i tweeted out a quote from
this book that when there are more
reports in favor of hypothesis a than
its in-first hypothesis b
it is not always sensible to prefer a to
b if we suspect that the amount of
evidence pointing to a rather than b has
been affected by how we set about
searching for it
so science research or just your daily
life understanding of facts should
revolve around proving things wrong
which is a funny thing to say
but speaking of human cognitive biases
this leads us on to actually the lessons
from lesson five that i'm just going to
throw into the section anyway
and that's the very human tendency to
search for or interpret information in a
way that confirms one's preconception
confirmation bias
we're quick to scrutinize information
that contradicts our beliefs and quick
to accept information that supports it
these illusions are not just necessarily
at the individual level but can also
work at the group level or institutional
level where they can have even more
significant impacts
so what can you do
well we have to accept that complete
objective analysis is impossible because
we're human and we have to interpret
reality for ourselves
but we can try to be as independent
honest and neutral in our analytic
judgments as we can
so lesson three estimations predictions
need an explanatory model as well as
sufficient data
someone who is intelligent is often
correct their prediction was right so
how do you go about making better
predictions
well assuming you followed the first two
lessons then you should be in a good
position to follow the hypothesis that
is most likely to be correct
but it is not that straightforward when
it comes to estimations
this is because it is not just about the
likelihood or the probability but the
expected value of the prediction
expected value is the probability of an
event multiplied by the measure of the
consequences for you of it happening
for example maybe i was wondering
whether i should bring a coat to work
and for me that depends on if it's
raining so i can work out a probability
of it raining
if i'm healthy and well then i'll be
pretty tolerant if it decides to rain
and i don't have a coat but if i was ill
it might not be great for me to be out
in the rain
and therefore despite having the same
probability whether or not it rains
my expected value differs
i'd be more likely to take the coat if i
was ill
now that's a very obvious example that i
feel like it's just common sense but you
can apply the same rationale to other
decisions you make
the other thing that's worth pointing
out is the fact that we are also limited
by how far we can actually estimate in
advance
the classic example here being
predicting the weather
i sometimes don't even trust weather
forecasts hours beforehand
and that's because there comes a point
where even the smallest disturbances set
in a train of sequence of cascading
changes that can tip weather systems or
just facts in general
so now to lesson four strategic notice
essentially knowing what to do in the
event that [ __ ] does happen
and in doing so we don't have to be so
surprised by surprises
so essentially strategic notice is
preparing for what's coming spotting
opportunities as well as identifying
dangers
now applying this in practice doesn't
seem trivial
but from my perspective it seems to be
more about being conscientious with your
information intake it requires active
processing
but in another sense this lesson mainly
just feels like a fancy way of saying be
prepared
so lesson five though in the book it's
lesson eight
imagine yourself on the shoes of the
person on the other side
the case study here is negotiations
i recently watched an interview with
chris foss on the diary of a ceo podcast
which talks about how to negotiate
and how you should ultimately let them
discover the best deal but what does
david suggest and what is the best deal
to take in a negotiation
well preparation again is key as
according to david it is always better
psychologically to be prepared to
advance to a known position then to
retreat into the unknown during a
negotiation
so for a negotiation it is best to
establish a batna first
the best alternative to a negotiated
agreement
work out what would be the best
alternative should the negotiation go
bad since you have confidence that you
already have your own route ready it's
easier to walk away from a negotiation
in trouble
when the alternative way ahead has
previously been established
and then in terms of the negotiation
itself
it's important to have the understanding
of why both parties have come to the
negotiation table
and therefore what they will need to
take away from the negotiation for it to
account as a success
and so that's why you need to imagine
yourself in the shoes of the person on
the other side and understand their
motivations their cultural backgrounds
as as we saw these cognitive and
confirmation biases it's very likely to
differ from what you might be thinking
and then the final lesson lesson six day
lesson 10
is that subversion and sedition are now
digital
the worlds of defense security and
intelligence now enter our daily lives
directly through the internet
subversion is thought of as external
interference in a nation's affairs to
overthrow the existing order of things
it's an outside-in process
whereas sedition is internal descent
inciting rebellion against the
constituted authority in estates
now the way i sort of think about this
lesson is more regarding echo chambers
and filter bubbles how the information
suggested to us only shows us part of
the story and to suit our world few
and it's important to know that we
shouldn't retreat into our own bubbles
and i didn't really have a solution or
the book doesn't really have a solution
for how to avoid getting into a bubble
so i think it's more about being aware
that you probably are in a bubble
already i mean if you're watching this
video you've definitely fallen into some
sort of bubble
but it's a good bubble but yes you
should break it because um don't get
limited by my world view
that was not an intelligent thing to do
so anyway on that weird ending point
what have i learned from this book one
of my key take-homes
well in general i found this book quite
dense and i obviously laughed out a lot
of detail
but the interesting thing about this
book well the funny thing actually is
that ultimately i don't think it
explains how spies think
because for them i think they've done it
and practiced it so many times that it
sort of comes naturally to them so they
don't really think about it they're not
thinking about their thinking they just
sort of do it
but my main taking from this book is
that as humans we are flawed and bound
to make bad decisions at times but we
can reduce this by realizing these facts
and taking the time
and putting in the effort to be more
considerate about how we come across
information
and how others feel and think and use
that to form our own opinions which will
ultimately make us more intelligent
it's all about conscious and deliberate
effort
and then one of my favorite parts of the
book
was the ethical rule that you should
also apply
which is when in doubt do the right
thing
i know we don't often know what the
right thing is and maybe it won't work
out as well if we do the right thing but
you can defend yourself in the knowledge
that you tried and you tried to do the
right thing
so you know what the right thing to do
now is
subscribe and watch this video here
but joking aside if you want to learn
more about intelligence at different
biological levels then you should watch
this video here
otherwise thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening